hi guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead's seventh
season premiere a day will come when you
won't be and if you haven't watch this
episode then what are you doing here get
the hell out dummy I don't want any more
Explorer blood on my hands going go okay
seriously I have never been saturd to be
right about something sure you know we
at new rockstars could brag about
predicting that it could be him and
Glenn Regan is going to kill Glenn
and/or Abraham that those two
specifically would be the ones to die
but you know I'm not happy about this
I love those two Bisquick brothers I'm
as shocked and as disgusted as you're
you know what let's bury that pain for
now bury it because this episode is
filled with interesting references and
subtle details that you might have
missed through all of your tears and
snot bubbles so let's pay tribute to
Glenn Abraham by analyzing this down
this episode it's what they would have
wanted and let's start with the opening
images this first scene is that
right-hand man seen at AMC released a
couple weeks ago which I already broke
down in this video but now take a look
at Rick's eyes here this particular shot
conveys two key things for this episode
one it signals to us that everything
will be seen in this episode is from
Rick's point of view so at no point do
we see any events or action that Rick
wasn't there for this is all about Rick
and - Rick is giving negan a particular
look here that this episode keeps coming
back - now this takes place right after
negan killed
Rick's friends and Rick's eyes are
filled with shock and anger and defiance
his first words to negan are I'm gonna
kill you which actually matches the
promise he made to Gareth and terminus
back in the season premiere of season 5
that's what I'm gonna use to kill you
and the through-line of this episode is
Rick's gradual collapse from defiance to
submission and this look is how we'll
check in with that transformation before
I move on I want to talk real quick
about the title this episode a day will
come when you won't be those words are
never said out loud in this episode and
that's because it's a reference to way
back in season 1 when dr. Jenner lets
Rick and his crew escape the exploding
CDC to have a chance at a decent life
grateful the day
we'll come when you won't be now that's
the literal reference of the title but I
think it takes on a deeper meaning as we
go on but I want to talk about just a
few things that are caught in the
opening credits so now that we know who
negan's victims are people have been
looking at Steven Yeun and Michael
Cudlitz title slides which been there
for a while but maybe there are some
foreshadowing clues like perhaps
Herschel's watch means Glenn's time is
up or this baby gray could mean Abraham
was gonna die this is kind of stretching
it if you ask me come on it's the The
Walking Dead everything is a visual
metaphor for death even the final title
slide of The Walking Dead has corroded
and rotted even more compared to last
season's but I do think that this title
slide under Loren cohan's name is worth
mentioning this is a photograph burning
which of course is a reference back to
season 4 when Maggie and Glenn were
finally reunited after being separated
and Maggie burned Glenn's only photo of
her saying that he would never need it
again because they would always be
together and of course that's especially
relevant now for obvious reasons okay
the one new title slide add to the
opening credits was Jeffrey Dean Morgan
right two things to point out here one
you can see the handle of Lucille in the
foreground but two if you look closely
in the fire there's another memorable
tool Nick and uses to punish people in
the comics and iron now I don't want to
say too much more because it could end
up being a spoiler for something that
comes up later in the season but I'm
sure we'll be talking about this again
soon now again I already talked about
the scene the other video so let's move
on to this scene with Rick and negan on
the RV and like you I was totally like I
swear to negan if this is just a road
trip with Rick and negan where we never
find out who dies I'm gonna continue
watching because I belong to you Walking
Dead I'm yours
okay so just a couple things I want to
point out here first the symbolism of
Rick's axe now throughout the comics the
axe is Rick's signature weapon but it
wasn't associated with Rick on the show
until recently and I'm pretty stoked
that they're finally doing this because
the axe as a symbol is key to Rick as a
leader so like the image of an axe is
associated with leaders from history
like George Washington who they say
chopped down a cherry tree as a boy and
of course Abraham Lincoln who famously
worked as a rail splitter
it's the archetypal tool of a man who
carries out justice himself who has to
make difficult split decisions and it's
interesting that throughout this episode
we rarely see negan holding the axe
himself he plunges it in the table he
hands it to Rick he drops it at the end
the episode meanwhile Rick has to go and
retrieve the axe and
he has to hold it and make the decision
about whether to cut his son's arm off
so just like King Arthur retrieving the
sword from the stone or any of the
Starks who have to swing the sword on
Game of Thrones
Rick is destined to be a true leader
despite how broken he may be feeling
right now now there were a few questions
you guys had here that I'm gonna try to
answer first how did the axe end up on
the roof if you look closely negan
clearly hooked his arm to flip it up
there I know I was a little thrown by
that too on my first viewing but more
importantly what is the point of this
whole side trip now as I said before
this episode is all about the transition
from defiance to submission and here
negan is trying to break Rick in and how
does negan do that he treats Rick like a
dog this whole episode is staged in a
way to make negan look like a cruel dog
trainer and Rick like the alpha dog of a
pack of wild hounds
so to point out a couple examples of
this the way Nikken dragged Rick to the
RV why doesn't he let Rick stand up that
would be a lot easier to bring him over
there but negan intentionally had him on
all fours like a dog and now negan is
ordering him to get my pack which is
basically like a twisted game of fetch
come on wake up Rick don't let yourself
be controlled like this okay Kyle oh
I'll go get the stick for you but just
this last time now notice the
parallelism of this sequence as Rick is
being haunted by the memories of his
possibly dead friends in his mind these
literally dead people are clawing at him
and haunting him in the physical sense
now at this point the episode we still
don't know who died how long are you
gonna draw this out I know but for
Rick's point of view all of his people
are dead or as good as dead and their
walker surrogates are attacking him
right now
now what do we think is going on when
Rick sees this hanging Walker remember
this is a guy who we saw back in the
season 6 finale the guy Simon sprayed
with an X and later hung from the
overpass now in that moment
Rick refused to end his suffering
because they needed the bullets but now
Rick is realizing how pointless that
logic was like they never even had a
chance
so the guilt and the realization of how
wrong his calculations were are finally
hitting him and real quick even though
there's really no way for Rick to know
this this is the same guy we saw at the
beginning of that episode the guy from
that library community who tried to
fight the Savior's so another way of
looking at this is since Rick is another
leader who's feeling foolish for taking
on negan and the Savior's this moment is
him looking into his future and he see
who he could become and feeling
terrified okay and before we move on to
the scene
I love the Edit that gets us there it's
a jump cut from Rick's face with the
dried blood stirring across it to Rick's
face without the blood so visually we
know that this takes place before
negan's kill now this scene starts off
as a replay from last season's finale
but from Rick's direct point of view
this time and if you followed negan's
eenie meenie miney mo rhyme along with
this movement it all pretty much matches
up to what we saw from last season but
what's most interesting is it doesn't
matter this was all just a game negan
and the show used to keep us in suspense
but in these final moments before he
says you are it you can see negan
looking down the line skipping several
people and just choosing someone and
that someone is Abraham
damnit now if negan could have picked
anyone why Abraham the red hair
obviously come on negan Jinger lives
matter but really this comes back to the
idea of looks that negan sees people
giving him and the idea of defiance and
Submission so negan doesn't want to kill
Rick because he prefers to leave this
group with some power structure just
with a leader he can control but with
Abraham he sees how big this guy is and
he sees his military fatigue pants this
guy is a warrior and he's staring back
at negan with rage even Abraham's last
words are an act of defiance
if negan didn't kill Abraham in this
moment not only would Rick have a strong
right-hand man to help him mount a
counter-attack another scenario could
have arisen where say if Rick folds to
negan Abraham could stage a mutiny rally
the Alexandrians and lead a campaign
against negan without Rick so by
selecting to kill Abraham negan proved
himself to be a smart strategic thinker
negan needs Rick in charge loyal to him
without any strong rivals to check
Rick's power or argue to overthrow negan
kind of like the setup he has with
Gregory at the hilltop and obviously
Abraham's death is a huge bummer made
even more heartbreaking by this mis'able
detail so check this out Abraham's hand
right before the bat comes down he makes
a peace sign then we cut to Sasha whose
eyes look down at his hand and she just
loses it and if you remember this is a
call back to last season episode 11 when
Abraham and Sasha exchanged peace signs
and that episode was a defining moment
of closure for Abraham when he
finally realized that a real future
might be possible but then sadly it was
that closure on his character arc that
made Abraham's death dramatically
justified now if you were me you were
probably feeling this mix of heartbreak
for Abraham plus a little relief that it
wasn't anyone else because even though
jeopardy Morgan seemed to hint that more
than one person might die he and then
AMC and everyone else connected to the
show they promise that only one person
would die still a lot of you clever
skeptics assume that there would be two
even that peace sign from Abraham might
have been a clue to - oh no regardless
we all felt it when this happened oh oh
I feel it everywhere why why Glenn well
for negan it's a direct consequence of
Glenn's outburst at the end of last
season which at that time he wrote off
as a freebie so when Daryl steps out of
line negan doles have the punishment on
the first offender but then also
narrative Lee speaking Glen has to die
okay easy easy according to the show not
to me we talked about this a lot last
season but Glen was very much the
sacrificial Christ figure he faced
certain death and miraculously survived
twice under the dumpster and then later
when he saved Maggie and Alexandria so
it makes sense at this third time he
would become a full martyr no dumpster
to save him this time but also like
Abraham I would argue Glenn's dramatic
role in this story was pretty much
complete he married Maggie and conceived
a child with her and that is way further
than most star-crossed lovers get he
also proved the power of rehabilitation
through his relationships with Nicholas
and Enid and now Glen has been
immortalized with this insane death
which will hopefully be used as a
rallying cry for Rick and Maggie and the
rest I could also see used as a creepy
jump-scare in YouTube videos don't don't
do it
are you gonna do it okay move [ __ ] god
no don't ever do that again
now I gotta fix my hair so yeah we're
all gonna miss Glenn it's super sad to
see him go but honestly it's better than
seeing him become boring and yeah
Glenn's death isn't just sad it's
revolting it's probably safe to say it
now but when is the person negan kills
an issue 100 of the comics so this death
was the one all of us comic readers were
dreading and props to Greg Nicotero and
the effects team for making Glenn's
death just as brutal as it is in the
comics down to the eyeball popping out
of his head
and that piece of flesh hanging from
Lucile and the one major difference
other than that unsettling twitching is
that instead of Glen's final word being
Maggie the show added to it yeah oh
thank you now a lot of viewers saw this
and we're like oh Glenn's brain stopped
working No
you heartless monsters I'll find you is
a sweetly poetic thing to say from one
star-crossed lover to the other Steven
Yeun and lauren cohan actually went into
this more on the talking dead but when
you think about it these two have been
separated again and again after the
prison during the Hurd Fiasco last
season and now separated for a third
time by death Glen is saying he will
find her again in the afterlife which is
beautiful but then again part of me
would have loved it if Glen's final
words or something like suck my nuts
Amram took my life now a lot of people
are saying that if both Abraham and Glen
died why did the show need the
cliffhanger like they could have ended
season six with Abraham's death and then
shocked us again at the start of season
seven with Glen and you know I hear that
but I still think this way works better
by the way AMC is not paying me to
defend the show they're to pay Chris
Hardwick plenty for that so here's my
thinking on this no matter what there
was already going to be plenty of
speculation over the summer that Glen
was going to die since Steven Yeun was
missing from said working on new
projects plus the comics and all the
other foreshadowing that the show has
been doing and at least now the show
kind of kept the mystery alive by
confusing us with clues pointing toward
multiple characters like apparently they
did shoot several alternate death scenes
of different characters and one of those
leaked online a couple days ago showing
Maggie taking the hit and I love how
instead of Glen Oh fine you
she just hocks a bloody loogie at negan
that it's true love okay shaking off our
grief and depression and moving on this
sequence with Rick returning to the RV
with the axis important for a few
reasons
so before when he left the RV he was
haunted by these images of his friends
and that scared him into fleeing the
walkers now the images of people
actually getting beaten with Lucille
motivates him into fighting back and if
you notice this scene is actually edited
with the same quick cutting as the
sequence in Episode nine of last season
when Rick almost lost Carl and the only
way Rick could feel useful was by
fighting back and hacking away at
walkers Rick is walking
all here he's defiant and that
confidence and hopefulness it's why we
see negan eyeing Rick's so closely when
he returns to the RV
negan is reading that book on Rick and
this look is still a look of defiance
so naturally negan continues this
running metaphor comparing Rick to a dog
that's being brought to heel
so like when Rick returns with the axe
negan says oh boy like he just returned
a ball or a stick and then he compares
Rick losing Abraham and Glenn to have in
his nuts cliff like a dog being neutered
yep
that's over and then later negan drags
Rick on all fours again before
commanding speak when you're spoken to
I'm not an expert but that Dog Whisperer
guy doesn't recommend to do any of this
stuff
now when negan talks about the look Rick
gave them it brings together the two
threads I've been talking about this dog
metaphor because when dogs make eye
contact it's a sign of submission but
also Rick's transition from defiance to
compliance and obedience which negan
completes by putting Rick through the
ultimate test cut off Karl's arm or
everyone dies and I gotta say this is a
pretty impressive twist this entire
episode from when negan waives Rick's
axe while talking about his right-hand
man to playing fetch with the axe to
repeatedly swinging the axe on the table
to cleaning it with peroxide those of us
to read the comics have her eyes glued
to that axe because we know Rick loses
his hand in the comics and we're
thinking okay Megan's totally gonna cut
off Rick Sam all right let's just get it
over with
but by forcing Rick to do this to Carl
it totally subverts those expectations
and everyone is watching the scene and
feeling genuine terror and anxiety which
somehow tops what we were feeling before
with Abraham and Glenn and the reason we
feel that tension is because we don't
want to see Rick break it hurts to see
characters we love die but it hurts even
more somehow to see a hero we've been
following for six seasons reduced to a
whimpering shaking snotty husk of a
person so thankfully the shattering of
Rick Grimes ego was as violent as this
scene gets negan drew the line on Carl's
arm literally now I should also point
out that this whole test is a reference
to the famous Old Testament story when
God ordered Abraham to kill his son
Isaac as a sacrifice to him and just at
the last second right before Abraham
went through with it God stopped him
because Abraham had proved
in his obedience yeah the god of the Old
Testament did not [ __ ] around and that
is clearly how the show is
characterizing negan he's not a
forgiving understanding or empathetic
person he's fire and brimstone he lays
out the rules demands offerings and
servitude and doles out extreme wrath to
those who don't follow him and I loved
the show including this overhead shot of
negan saying
Tata as he leaves which is taken
directly from the comics when I read
that I didn't know how it would play on
the show but jeopardy Morgan totally
makes it work and I almost forgot to
mention this but check out this Savior
in the background with the chainsaw
I assume that's just a scare tactic
maybe he helped chop down all those
trees for the roadblock they set up but
come on man what are you gonna do with
it we're already traumatized now a
really cool detail that some of you
might have caught as the Savior's lead
you can see one of them taking a
Polaroid of Glen's bashed in head it's
an awesome call back to episode 12 of
last season when Glen saw a bunch of
similar photos in the Savior's compound
that was what convinced him that these
were bad people and stabbing them in
their sleep was justified that was a
pivotal moment for Glen that was the
first time he murdered someone and the
moment he lost his innocence so it's
cool to see that moment come full circle
with Glen probably ending up on that
same wall and in these final moments
there's clearly a lot of self blame to
go around
Daryl for example took the swing at
negan that led to Glen getting killed
even though that punch was pretty
satisfying and it showed negan at least
isn't untouchable now I'm sure Daryl
will be doing a lot of thinking about
that on the way to wherever the Savior's
are taking him but also let's be honest
the responsibility really falls on Rick
here he was the leader who assumed
incorrectly that they could defeat
negan's people outright but also
Maggie's probably feeling like it was
her sudden sickness that forced everyone
out in the open but then you can go back
further and Aaron's probably like but I
was the one who recruited these nice
people into that was Andrea it's my
fault the two of them are dead now if
Eugene's thinkin we'll crap I was the
one who lied about being a scientist to
get people to come up north in the first
place and then the walkers are like
llama weed people Saul sorry Clini
neighbor
no no no yeah we're gonna hear a lot
about everyone's guiltily coming weeks
and then of course Rick's vision of
everyone together around the dinner
table was an interesting touch to say
the least a little cheesy in my opinion
but it's also pretty touching when you
consider that in real life cast members
take each other out to dinner when one
of them gets killed on the show so this
moment was kinda sweet to be honest I
kind of expected the camera to pan
around and show like Dom at the head of
the table like Uncle broom so go zoom
and then that like sad music comes up as
Glenn and Abraham race off in the sunset
Dodge Challenger vs. firetruck I'm just
saying that would have been one way to
go but this spring's made my closing
images just like in the opening shot we
return to this close-up of Rick's eyes
and we see how the look that negan
noticed has changed from pure anger and
defiance to fear and obedience the look
that negan wanted now again the titleist
episode is the day will come when he
won't be which is a reminder of dr.
Jenner's warning about Rick's day of
reckoning the day when he wouldn't be
grateful for avoiding a simple painless
fate and that day has come but I almost
think that this title has a deeper
meaning now when you look at the opening
image and say those words out loud it
kind of sounds cynical like they're
coming from negan the day will come when
he won't be defiant hopeful confident
and instead you'll crumble and fall
that's what negan does to rate this
episode but when you say those words
over this final shot it leaves us with
this kind of sense of hope as if they're
coming from Rick's fallen friends as a
message of encouragement Rick right now
you may feel broken but a day will come
when you won't be okay so some lingering
questions one was this worth the wait
last season the show's producers
justified the cliffhanger by saying
negan's introduction was the end of the
story of season six while who died was
the start of the season seven story and
now that we've seen it what do you think
does that reasoning hold up should they
have split up the deaths like I
mentioned and then to has the violence
of this show crossed a line for you I
mean it shouldn't because this show in
the comics is based on have always been
super super violent honestly for me the
only shot that came close to crossing
the line was this one trigger warning
Glenn head caved in his hands
twitchy you do not see Glenn's hands
twitching in the comics that was added
to the show for me that was a little
extreme but you know it didn't stop me
from like finishing my polish yeah three
what will this show become without Glenn
and Abraham
I know it feels rough right now but
having read the comics some really
interesting things start to happen after
both these characters leave the series
and I don't really know how the show
would have fit them into these
storylines I know I will miss all of
Abraham's one-liners but honestly it's
looking like negan has discovered
they're also with Glenn gone
the only remaining original characters
from season 1 are Rick Karl Carol Daryl
and technically Morgan so I wonder if
we'll lose any others for what does this
mean for Maggie
it's interesting how at the end of the
episode Rick's priority was everyone's
safety
whereas Maggie's seemed to care less
about her own health than she did about
Rick getting back to Alexandria and
getting ready for war that would be one
silver lining to losing Glenn also do
you think negan is truly evil every
watched that moment when negan realized
that Glenn and Maggie were together his
apology
almost seems genuine now negan is
obviously the most sadistic character
we've seen on The Walking Dead but I
wonder if Jeffrey Dean Morgan who is so
freakin likable will bring out whatever
heart this character may have and
finally where are Heath and Tara oh
that's right no one cares
now next week's episode is called the
well and the promo suggests that we will
catch up with Carol and Morgan in this
new place called the kingdom as well as
an introduction to the new character
king Ezekiel and if you thought negan
was over-the-top wait till you get a
load of this guy okay let me know what
you think in the comments and thanks for
watching I'm really gonna try to get
these out as quickly as possible every
week hopefully we won't run into any
technical issues with a certain TV
network but if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share it with all of your
Walking Dead friends if you really like
us like liked like us you can donate to
us on patreon so thanks too much all of
our current patrons we like like you
guys too it's nice of you guys really
that we're even able to do these videos
if you are contributing yet it's a
really cool way to be part of our team
here new rock stars so if you aren't
already we'd love to have your support
you can hit me up on Twitter a TA boss
with any theories or questions or things
that you notice in the episode or follow
new rock stars on Twitter at new rock
stars for updates on when our future
videos are coming out alright thanks for
watching bye
[Music]